hi everyone it's claire i'm an
illustrator animation student and avid
ipad user and i'm back again to give you
the rundown on apple's newest ipad the
ipad air 2022
i really like the ipad air 202 and it's
the first ipad in this review series so
far that i'm going to say it's better
than the ipad air 2020. watches of our
previous ipad videos would know that i
love the 2020 model for its size
lightness and its magnetic and bluetooth
attachments to the 2nd gen apple pencil
and the magic keyboard so the ipad 2022
was a surefire hit for me with the
upgrade of the high power m1 chip paired
with a liquid retina display on a very
similarly designed device breaking down
its key traits this year's ipad is true
to its name super light and easy to slot
into a backpack for work and school it
blends in perfectly with textbooks and
stationery making it feel right at home
the 2022 is 9.7 by 7 by 0.24 inches
exactly the same as the 2020 air with
its companion products the 2nd gen apple
pencil and magic keyboard the tiny 22 is
a lighter and more compact alternative
to a laptop for many people although i
prefer the typing experience of a
mechanical keyboard the magic keyport is
definitely a lighter and minimalist
option to pair with the ipad air and
it's much more considerate to other
classmates and co-workers when running
your thoughts off on the keys the thin
keys make typing effortless and easy
when you want to quickly type a short
paragraph on the bus home or during a
busy lecture and if writing or doodling
your thoughts is more your style the 2nd
gen apple pencil can be your new best
friend like the 2020 model the 2022 air
has magnets around the edges for the 2nd
gen apple pencil to connect seamlessly
to it via bluetooth this makes it easy
for safekeeping too as it firmly sticks
to the side of the ipad the 2022 is also
the third longest lasting battery life
ipad with about 10 hours of life only
outlasted by the ipad pros by one or two
hours this makes it a good companion
during the working day because the 2022
model has the familiar wireless
bluetooth connections to both the apple
magic keyboard and the 2nd gen apple
pencil this is an easy switch over for
apple fans who already have these
gadgets for their 2020 model but why
should they switch over because of the
m1 chip booster that makes this 2022
model comparable to the mammoth 2021
ipad pro in terms of display quality and
computing power here at geek culture we
love our keyboards especially with the
all-new logitech mx keys mini an elegant
and functional keyboard its ultra
responsive rounded keycaps are super
stable and quiet for more productivity
there are buttons to enable dictation
microphone audio control and emojis the
backlit keys illuminate when you get
close and matches the lighting of the
environment you're in it lasts up to 10
days on a full charge or 5 months with
the backlights turned off to find out
more about the logitech mx keys mini and
their latest range of products head over
to logitech.com
i have to be honest and say that the
science of the 2021 pro was too large
and heavy for me to carry around all the
time but that display on a smaller ipad
is truly a dream come true in the 2022
air the liquid retina display allows for
a higher level of immersion within games
videos and design work in a compact
device the 2022 airs the same size and
width as the 2020 air with the 8 core
cpu and 8 core gpu this new model is up
to 60 faster than the previous model
ipad air with twice the graphics
processing speed i tested this out on
the procreate version 5.25 3d model
painting and i was done by how accurate
and detailed the rendering was on the
model because of the liquid retina
display i feel like my illustration and
details in color and lighting truly
popped this helped me to immerse myself
for long periods of time working on
these drawings for school and relaxation
i definitely have the m1 chip to thank
as well for the smooth processing and
quick response time of the 2022 air
during my use of the 3d texture painting
tool i thought the ipad would lag
horrendously as my laptop usually does
when i'm rendering lighting and textures
with 3d models for school however
procreate and the 22 air allows me to do
rendering of everything lighting
textures and models seamlessly in 60
frames per second on top of that it
responds to any changes i make in real
time i can literally change the lighting
and paint new textures with zero lag
making this the smoothest and easiest
texture painting that i've done in a
very long time even on the 2020 model i
experienced zero lag time between
putting the tip of the apple pencil down
the screen and each joke i made allowing
my thoughts to flow freely onto the
screen however to my surprise procreate
on the 2022 air does not support as many
layers as the ipad pro despite having
the m1 chip at 300 dpi the 3d22 air
supports a maximum of 26 layers at a4
size 11 layers at a3 size and 120 layers
at a 4x6 photo size
this is in comparison to the numbers
from the ipad pro from a video last year
at dpi 300 44 layers at a3 size 92
layers at a4 size and 250 layers and the
4x6 photo size while these restraints
are right for me this might make the
2021 pro more suitable than the 2022 air
for artists handling layer heavy
projects while we're talking about more
technical topics i find that the m1 chip
does make a slight difference to
downloading and uploading speeds however
this is not very significant to me i
find that it only truly shines when
tackling graphics heavy applications or
taking a few apps running at the same
time without lagging any of them in
conclusion i highly recommend the 2022
ipad not just for artists like me
dabbling in different kinds of digital
art and media i recommend it to working
adults and students who are looking for
a compact device that can support their
resource intensive tasks on the go it's
definitely for people who like their
device displays like their fried chicken
crispy and buttery for their art and
games the m1 ipad air 2022 with liquid
retina display is the way to go remember
to follow us on all our socials and like
this video subscribe if you haven't and
this is claire signing off i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you